avec un beau soleil samedi 20 février la
croquante de saint germain en laye a
fait carton plein presque toutes les
places étaient réservées la veille
c'est-à-dire plus de 207 parcours
d'accrobranche et sont disponibles il y
en a pour tous les goûts en fait quand
vous venez ici on vous répartis sur les
parcours en fonction de votre taille et
de votre personnalité si vous êtes
plutôt craintif plutôt à l'aise ou
plutôt téméraire
comme on dit on vous êtes accompagné du
début jusqu'à la fin
dans le choix des parcours dans
l'initiation sur les parcours
d'entraînement et dans les différentes
activités qu'on propose ici
le parc est récent il a été ouvert en
l'accrobranche n'est pas la seule
activité possible sur le site
on essaie de s'inscrire dans une
démarche éco responsable donc on propose
des courses d'orientation des jeux sur
le thème de la nature anniversaire team
building et stages qui peuvent durer de
deux jours à une semaine
le parc est accessible à tous ses
activités en extérieur permettent de se
retrouver entre amis ou en famille vu
que les restos sont fermées et les bars
on ferme et on s'est dit que c'était la
seule activité possible à faire en plein
air on voulait réserver en fait
finalement ce matin mais c'était au
complet donc on s'est dit qu'on
passerait tout simplement sur site
directement mort s'il y avait la place
aux finales nationales ons on est bien
tombé on a l'impression d'être libre
dans l'ailleurs chose qu'on n'est pas
sur terre aujourd'hui donc le fait
d'être dans l'herbe assez bien on sont
libérés tout ce que j'ai actuellement
donc ça fait du bien au mental le parc
ouvrira plus tôt cette semaine à 10
heures pour accueillir davantage de
clients